tf1 20 heures avec jean claude bourret
froid persistant neige abondante roux
dangereuse
un conseil restez chez vous jacques
chirac au rassemblement rpr porte de
pantin le ps n'est pas un parti de
gouvernement françois mitterrand n'est
pas un homme politique responsable de
leader en campagne jean lecanuet pour le
cds et jean-jacques servan-schreiber
pour le parti radical entretien à sadate
shimon perez en autriche
sadate espère que le dialogue sera
poursuivi madame mademoiselle monsieur
bonsoir
la neige est tombée ou va tomber dans
les prochaines 48 heures sur une bonne
partie de la france en bretagne par
exemple de nombreuses voitures ont été
abandonnées cet après-midi par leur
conducteur sur la nationale 12
à la suite d'accidents dus au verglas
même situation dans les charentes en
corrèze ou dans la région de brive
plusieurs dizaines de poids lourds sont
bloqués par la neige neige dans l'est
avec 20 cm d'épaisseur près des cols
vosgiens qui reste cependant accessible
véhicules équipés finalement comme le
disait monsieur météo dans notre édition
de 13 heures on n'aurait plus vite fait
de donner les régions de france où il ne
neige pas jean-claude perpère la
provence et la côte d'azur n'ont pas
échappé aux mauvaises conditions
météorologiques dans l'arrière pays
niçois
la couche de neige recouvrant les
immeubles atteignez 15 cm et hier soir
le train des pignes entre nice et digne
a été bloqué par une congère à marseille
aux alentours d'aix-en-provence la neige
verglacée a provoqué de nombreux
accidents
circulation perturbée tout aujourd'hui
également dans la vallée du rhône si
près d'orange une congère dépassé par le
vent a fermé pendant une bonne partie de
la journée
l'une des voies de l'autoroute a7 la
nationale 85 la route napoléon coupé par
trois avalanches n'a pu être rouverte
qu'en début d'après midi
actuellement toutes les routes de la
région sont ouvertes à la circulation
mais reste dangereuse dans les alpes du
sud
seule la station d'isola 2000 restent
inaccessibles
cependant la neige a continué à tomber
sur lyon où la couche atteignait ce
matin 15 cm occasionnant deux
embouteillages et condamnant les pistes
des aéroports les vosges le centre la
bretagne et l'aquitaine n'ont pas été
épargné par le mauvais temps
la couche de neige atteint parfois plus
d'un mètre sur les routes des pyrénées
le col du puymorens par exemple entre la
france et l'andorre est fermé pour la
nuit
si la plupart des routes de montagne
sont ouvertes à l'exception de quelques
cols la formation de verglas est à
redouter durant la nuit le sample de la
circulation routière de rosny-sous-bois
conseille donc aux vacanciers d'attendre
le jour pour rejoindre les stations de
sports d'hiver
un autre les véhicules doit être équipé
de chaînes et de pneus neige
oui la sécurité civile lance précisément
un appel à la prudence si vous devez
prendre le volant attention en raison du
froid qui va s'accentuer le risque de
verglas va se généraliser sur une bonne
partie de la france ce soir dans notre
journal de 23h30 un responsable de la
gendarmerie fera le bilan de cette
journée
déjà cet après midi en haute et -4
degrés à limoges et nancy 0 degrés à
toulouse 2 degrés à grenoble brest et
marseille et 7 degrés à nice demain
matin il y aura encore des chutes de
neige dans le nord et le nord-est où les
routes seront verglacées neige également
demain après-midi de la bretagne aux
pyrénées politique à un mois des
législatives la mobilisation s'accentue
pour chaque partie engagée dans la
bataille aujourd'hui le fait marquant
c'est le grand rassemblement populaire
organisé par le rpr porte de pantin à
paris des dizaines de milliers de
militants et de sympathisants
les estimations varient entre 60000 et
100000 se sont rassemblés pour écouter
plusieurs orateurs dont michel debré et
surtout monsieur jacques chirac qui a
pris la parole cet après midi un peu
avant 17 heures un résumé de cette
journée par jacques hébert et jacques le
noir se voulant à la fois ferme et
rassurant jacques chirac a choisi cet
après-midi de diviser ce discours de la
porte de pantin en deux chapitres d'égal
longueur est d'abord une sévère mise en
garde contre une éventuelle victoire de
la gauche je retiendrai ces quelques
phrases l'union de la gauche est
mensongère c'est une entreprise de
maquillage non il n'y a pas de majorité
de rechange parce que le parti
socialiste n'est pas un parti de
gouvernement
parce que son premier secrétaire n'est
pas un homme politique responsable parce
que les socialistes sont des trompeurs
tous azimuts
deuxième volet de ce discours le
programme du rpr programme que jacques
chirac a eu l'occasion de développer au
cours du périple qu'il a entrepris en
france depuis quelques mois le président
du rpr se veut intransigeant sur
l'indépendance et la sécurité des
français conscients du caractère
intolérable du chômage
exigeant sur le progrès social et
ambitieux pour l'économie à noter sur ce
dernier point une critique ouverte
contre la gestion de raymond barre la
réglementation des prix a dit jacques
chirac est un monument de mauvais
dirigisme qui paralyse et industrie
et n'empêche pas la hausse des prix
enfin jacques chirac s'est voulu
apaisant pas un mot sur ses partenaires
pas un mot sur ce qui a pu diviser ces
derniers temps les états majors de la
majorité et puis sans reprendre le mot
de recours le président du rpr a parlé
de l'ultime rempart que constitue le
rassemblement pour la république
on le voyait il faut beaucoup de
mauvaises foire où beaucoup d'ignorance
de la part de nos adversaires pour
prétendre que nous sommes les tenants de
je ne sais quel immobilisme comme si le
gaullisme n'avait pas toujours été dans
l'histoire de notre pays celui qui a su
mettre en oeuvre les réformes les plus
importantes et les plus audacieuses que
notre pays ait connu ce que nous
proposons aujourd'hui comme hier c'est
le contraire de l'immobilisme c'est le
mouvement
c'est l'audace c'est le progrès c'est le
colis nos détracteurs
par calcul tente de mettre sur notre
rassemblement l'étiquette infamante à
leurs yeux de conservateurs ont raidi
l'un ce point la mémoire courte depuis
bientôt 38 ans chaque fois qu'une idée
généreuse a été lancée en france chaque
fois qu'une action de progrès social a
été entreprise
c'est le général de gaulle et ceux qui
l'ont soutenu qui en ont été les
initiateurs
la première résistance à l'oppression
allemande chouchon les gaullistes et
personne d'autre
la sécurité sociale le vote des femmes
ce sont les gaullistes l'indépendance
des peuples d'afrique
ce sont les gaullistes le développement
sans précédent de la scolarité et des
droits sociaux dans notre nation
ce sont les gaullistes et ceux qui
pendant dix ou douze ans sous la
quatrième république sous la
responsabilité des vétérans des deux
perdent et consorts ont assumé
on tâche mais la responsabilité des
affaires de notre pays
qu'ont ils fait pour la france sinon de
l'abbé ses côtés mais pour le peuple
français comptent ils à mettre à leur
actif comme réformes sociales généreuses
kotil feydeau que d'interdire que le
général de gaulle puissent parler à la
radio ou à la télévision
compagnon mes amis et vous tous qui est
ici ce soir
n'écoutez pas les voies du renoncement
de la lâcheté et de doute vous n'êtes
pas de ceux qui pactisent quand il
s'agit de l'avenir de la france
vous n'êtes pas de ceux qui désertent
quand l'adversaire est menaçant et
résolu vous n'êtes pas de ceux qui
baissent les bras et abandonne à la
désespérance
vous êtes le peuple de france vous êtes
les fils et les filles de ceux qui ont
enseigné au monde les chemins de la
liberté
proville beauchamp se souviennent encore
des combats passés il porte témoignage
que dans l'aura
vous savez défendre la cause de la
liberté oui vous savez ce qu'est le
courage et le courage de demain c'est de
relever l'immense défi que j'ai à la
france l'entreprise collectiviste avons
l'audace à vos la résolution à vos
l'espérance et nous l'emporterons cette
victoire dans un mois oui nous devons
gagner
oui nous allons gagner nous gagnerons
ensemble cette bataille de france vive
la république vive la france
pour ce grand rassemblement du rpr la
plupart des militants chiraquien avaient
quitté leur province dès le milieu de la
nuit
ils sont arrivés au petit matin
provoquant une affluence inhabituelle
dans les gares parisiennes
le rassemblement pour la république en
effet n'avait guère ménagé ses efforts
57 prince spéciaux emile car pour
ramasser militants et sympathisants dans
tous les coins de france
dès 10 heures donc la grande fête du rpr
commencé dans l'immense hall de la porte
de pantin
c'est là que s'était donnée rendez vous
plusieurs dizaines de milliers de
personnes
beaucoup n'avaient guère dormi de la
nuit tous sont restés sur place souvent
debout pendant neuf heures d'affilée
tenue de rigueur
le bonnet phrygien le tee shirt et le
badge à l'éffigie de jacques chirac
partout des banderoles représentant les
différentes régions
une multitude de drapeaux et des croix
de lorraine et ce public survolté bien
sûr malgré la température glaciale a
réservé un accueil enthousiaste à
jacques chirac à la tribune tous les
candidats rpr aux élections législatives
et puis aussi le ban et l'arrière ban du
gaullisme parmi eux trois anciens
premiers ministres de la vème république
dont michel debré michel debré qui s'est
d'ailleurs taillé un beau succès dans le
long réquisitoire qu'il prononça contre
la gauche
à midi ce fut la pause déjeuner plus de
30 mille plateaux avaient été préparés
pour la circonstance et vers 15 heures
la kermesse
après le repas reprenait en musique
cette fois nicoletta et les compagnons
de la chanson s'efforçant de contenir
l'impatience du public car celui-ci
n'attendait qu'un moment le discours de
jacques chirac
ce fut le clou de la manifestation ce
fut aussi le point final de la journée
aujourd'hui le président du rpr
montrer la capacité de mobilisation de
son rassemblement ce soir il a gagné son
pari
oui tous les ministres et personnalités
repères étaient présents la tribune
derrière jacques chirac pendant son
discours mais les observateurs
politiques ont tout de même noté
l'absence de monsieur jacques chaban
delmas
d'autres réunions meeting et
déclarations évidemment marqué ce samedi
vous allez en prendre connaissance grâce
la deuxième partie de ce journal les
législatives avec d'abord un extrait de
ce que monsieur georges marchais à 10,1
ans
or aujourd'hui vous pouvez mieux voir
combien nous avions raison tout est allé
en effet très vite ces jours ci regardez
ce qui se passe
d'abord voici quinze jours
françois mitterrand déclare je cite nous
les socialistes nous serons plus à
l'aise pour demander des sacrifices aux
travailleurs autrement dit autrement dit
le parti socialiste tournant le dos à la
grande politique sociale du programme
commun annonce qu'il poursuivra la
politique d'austérité
ensuite après avoir annoncé à marseille
puis avoir démenti que les réformes de
structure ne seraient entamées qu'en
1981 françois mitterrand déclare à m à
propos de la sidérurgie qu'avant
d'envisager une éventuelle
nationalisation il faudra je cite un
plan intermédiaire de 18 mois pour faire
le point de l'héritage du capitalisme
dans ces conditions comment les
travailleurs ne s'interrogerait il pas
comment ne se demanderaient t-il pas
mais que veut le parti socialiste ou
veut-il nous emmener nous communistes
nous avons une position claire nous n'en
avons jamais ch
g et nous n'en changerons pas nous
voulons le changement nous voulons un
gouvernement de gauche avec des
ministres communistes
nous voulons une politique pour les
travailleurs et nous voulons l'union
robert fabre en n2 les militants
communistes éprouverez un trouble
certain si les dirigeants de leur parti
refusait à l'accord de désistement
les radicaux de gauche comme le parti
socialiste sont fermement décidés à
faire respecter cette règle en faveur du
candidat de gauche arrivé en tête le 12
mars le comité national d'action laïque
qui regroupe la fen le syndicat national
des instituteurs et les parents d'élèves
cornec appelle à voter pour des
changements fondamentaux changement qui
permettrait de doter le pays d'un
service public d'éducation unique et
laïque jean pierre soisson rtl2
conditions s'imposent aux diverses
formations de la majorité
premièrement soutien au président de la
république et la reconnaissance de son
rôle dans la conduite de la nation
deuxièmement l'acceptation de la règle
des désistements réciproques
jean pierre soisson a précisé qu'il ne
voyait aucune raison d'exclure de la
majorité le parti radical
enfin le conseil national du parti des
forces nouvelles appellera à voter au
second tour des élections pour les
candidats je cite les plus à droite de
la majorité
chaque samedi soir depuis un mois
maintenant vous avez rendez vous avec un
grand leader politique en campagne
électorale
après jacques chirac françois mitterrand
jean pierre soisson et georges marchais
voici ce soir les portraits de
jean-jacques servan-schreiber et jean
lecanuet dans cette bataille des
législatives un double portrait signé
jacquier
jean lecanuet a ouvert la campagne
électorale du cds le centre des
démocrates sociaux cette semaine à rouen
avec la venue du premier ministre
monsieur raymond barre jean lecanuet
sénateur maire de rouen va faire
campagne pour les candidats de son parti
et pour l'un des deux courants de la
majorité
l'udf l'union pour la démocratie
française lui-même a finalement décidé
de ne pas se présenter aux élections
législatives jean lecanuet entre donc
assez tard en campagne mais comme il est
l'un des meilleurs orateurs de la
majorité
il va parcourir la france jusqu'aux
élections sur le plan national cette
campagne les cds se fera derrière le
président de la république il s'agit de
se placer au coeur de cette majorité
présidentielle depuis longtemps souhaité
celle du france gouverner au centre mais
il s'agit aussi d'affirmer dans ce
courant
la personnalité du cds avec le programme
du parti l'autre solution tiré à 40000
exemplaires et à partir du 20 février
avec un album de bande dessinée
cet album a été tirée à 100 mille
exemplaires il sera vente lui par les
fédérations du cds et aussi chez les
marchands de journaux dans la bande
dessinée nouveau politique vous
présenter en images dans un langage
clair
cette campagne nationale est supervisé
par bernard stasi qui en est responsable
devant le bureau politique
mais ce qui est encore plus important
pour le cds c'est la bataille dans les
circonscriptions où se présente c'est
quand ces candidats qui ne bénéficie pas
du soutien d'un puissant appareil de
militants ont reçu des cours de
formation de spécialistes du marketing
par exemple ici à châtellerault les
candidats de la région du centre sont
venus écouter le conseil de monsieur et
caire dont le métier est la vente par
correspondance et à domicile
pour un candidat aux élections le grand
problème est de savoir s'organiser de ne
pas gaspiller son temps où son argent
ainsi ces candidats ont appris à
programmer leur campagne selon un
calendrier très précis pour ces
candidats la découverte marketing
politique
copier sur les techniques de publicité
et de vente est souvent une grande
surprise la campagne électorale du parti
radical de monsieur servan-schreiber a
de nombreux points communs avec celle du
cds après avoir tenu 15 meetings
régionaux du mois de septembre au mois
de décembre
jean-jacques servan-schreiber va
maintenant se consacrer à des réunions
de soutien aux candidats dans les
circonscriptions le parti radical lui
aussi doit travailler avec un nombre de
militants qui n'est pas comparable avec
celui des grandes formations politiques
ils sont environ 15000 il s'agit
traditionnellement d'un parti de
notables qui se situe au centre gauche
mais dans un scrutin très serré comme
sera sans doute celui des extraits du
canard ils pourront peser d'un poids
très lourd
jean-jacques servan-schreiber a été l'un
des artisans actif de la constitution de
l'udf l'union pour la démocratie
française et les candidats radicaux font
campagne sous la bannière du président
comparé aux formidables machines des
grands partis l'organisation radicale
paraît évidemment un petit peu artisanal
les responsables de la campagne pour
compenser la faiblesse des moyens
doivent eux aussi faire appel aux
techniques du marketing politique
les candidats du parti radical ont suivi
un séminaire à la mi décembre où des
spécialistes leur ont donné des cours
d'élocution jouent ils ont appris à
concevoir une affiche à planifier leur
campagne à s'initier à l'audiovisuel
ils font campagne sous le sigle bien sûr
l'udf en y ajoutant les thèmes radicaux
présentait dans un fascicule les espoirs
pour la france tiré à 4 millions
d'exemplaires
mais le parti radical comme le cds
comptes auront beaucoup dans la campagne
nationale sur les qualités de leur
leader qu'ils sont capables d'affronter
n'importe quel débat à la radio ou à la
télévision les meetings étant utilisé en
force d'appoint pour montrer une
présence sur le terrain
dans le domaine social une seule
information qui me parvient d'ailleurs à
l'instant il s'agit de la suspension de
la grève du remorquage au havre cette
suspension de grève a été décidée à 80%
d'un vote à bulletin secret
le président égyptien monsieur anouar el
sadate a rencontré alsace bourg en
autriche le chef de l'opposition
travailliste israélienne monsieur shimon
peres le chef de l'état égyptien et
l'ancien ministre israélien de la
défense ont fait le poids des
négociations et des possibilités davance
pour la paix au proche orient
michel bader comme un pèlerin anouar el
sadate continue son chemin
cette fois la station se situe en
autriche qui pour quelques heures
reçoit le chef de l'état égyptien
l'autriche dont la neutralité notoire
représente le cadre idéal pour une
rencontre entre le leader d'une certaine
paix arabe et le représentant de
l'opposition israélienne mais aussi une
poignée de main qui appellera peut-être
des critiques des deux côtés du jourdain
ainsi que chez les faucons des deux
parties toujours est il que le voyage en
europe du chef de l'état égyptien
s'inscrit dans un périple qui le
conduira demain à paris et lundi au
vatican comme s'il voulait faire
comprendre à l'europe sa formule de pair
au kazoo et en cas d'échec
selon la presse égyptienne le pèlerinage
d'anouar el sadate se traduirait par une
condamnation entre guillemets des
responsables américains au sujet des
implantations israéliennes en
territoires arabes
ce voyage et surtout cette rencontre
avec shimon peres adversaires politiques
de menahem begin
poite aussi avoir un caractère
d'avertissement à l'égard de l'équipe
actuellement au pouvoir à jérusalem
réponse peut-être le main au cours de la
visite qu'elle noir al sadate fera à
valéry giscard d'estaing précisément
l'ambassade d'égypte en france à 24
heures de l'arrivée à paris du président
égyptien a fait distribuer aux
journalistes un document soulignant que
l'initiative de paix égyptienne est une
phase avancée de la paix et non pas le
début d'un processus
il s'agit par delà les mots pour le
président égyptien d'entretenir
l'accélération obtenu par son voix
un jeu spectaculaire en israël pour les
egyptiens d'ailleurs le début de ce
processus de paix a été engagé dès le 22
novembre 1967 lorsque le conseil de
sécurité des nations unies a adopté à
l'unanimité la fameuse résolution 242 au
liban après quelques fusillades la nuit
a été relativement calme mais la brusque
flambée de violences provoquées par un
simple incident devant une caserne fait
craindre le pire
de beyrouth notre envoyé spécial 10
heures tous les abbés route après une
journée de combats dans le quartier
chrétien nine rayman et les dégâts sont
importants
voitures brûlées l'immeuble défoncé
criblé d'éclats d'obus impact sur les
façades vitres des fenêtres cassées par
le souffle des explosions démontre
l'importance des incidents et la volonté
de la force arabe de dissuasion
d'imposer sa loi comme le précise cet
ancien président du conseil qui est allé
à damas avec 50 députés libanais pour
rencontrer le président assad
quelle est la position si rien est
pratiquement je peux vous dire que les
dirigeants syriens sont trop énervé des
six est passé au liban
ils disent qu'ils sont venus au liban
pour imposer la paix seulement pas pour
d'autres choses et ils ont été traités
de cette façon ils croient qu'ils se
sont se sont pas des actes isolés qui se
sont passées au liban derniers jours
mais quelque chose qui est beaucoup plus
grave et ils sont ils veulent être ferme
en ce sens pour en finir avec thau csu
l'histoire du côté mourabitoun libanais
nassérien progressiste alliés aux
palestiniens pendant la dernière guerre
c'est la mobilisation la dernière guerre
et 40 mille morts n'ont pas rapproché
les différentes tendances
à propos de toute cette situation qui se
passe aujourd'hui au liban
voyez nous sommes en état d' alerte et
et nous voyons très très nettement la
situation et nous sommes prêts pour
toute éventualité qui peuvent se poser
sur le territoire et cette éventualité
pourra se poser comment vous voyez si
les français sont racistes veulent
augmenter ou bien élargir l'éventail de
ses accrochages partout sa vie ils
veulent dépasser maintenant leur
accrochage avec les troupes syriennes et
ils veulent faire une des accrochages
plus large c'est à dire avec les forces
progressistes et peut-être la résistance
palestinienne
la page aux sportifs de ce journal avec
d'abord du ski descente hommes h monique
ce matin sur la piste verte des houches
c'est le canadien kent red que vous
voyez sur ces images qui remportait
l'épreuve
cette compétition comptait pour la coupe
du monde de ski ken raid a été crédité
du temps de 2 minutes et 8 secondes 11
centièmes deuxième
un autre canadien s'il vous plaît dave
murray et troisième l'allemand de
l'ouest michael veille tu mets une
surprise plutôt bonne pour les français
patrice pellat finet il est en effet
arrivé 5e mais le tort de terminer sa
descente il l'expliquera dans quelle
condition à daniel pautrat
disons que depuis surtout le début
janvier j'ai essayé de mettre toutes les
chances de mon côté ce que c'était très
difficile de descendre vu que ça
marchait pas du tout alors fallait plus
que ça pouvait plus durer comme ça chez
c'est tombé un peu tous les problèmes je
fais ma petite vie tout seul au sein de
l'équipe de france n'a pas toujours plu
à tout le monde
enfin ça porte ses résultats maintenant
aurait qu'est-ce que vous avez changé
j'ai changé dit l'oncle et trouver une
autre paire de skis pot-pourri six
manèges ronde et puis j'ai pris une
autre combinaison
moralement ça va faire je pense que
moralement c'est très important
c'est plus que morale même pente de plus
que morale aussi maison que pour faire
de la descente à l'heure actuelle il
faut mieux avoir toutes les chances de
son côté
on n'a pas tellement compris sens alors
vous pensez que vous n'êtes pas dans les
meilleures conditions discorde équipe de
france maintenant c'est prouvé
aujourd'hui on importe la preuve je
pense on voit les autres français sont
tous à 2,14 sais pas d'habitude il
arrive à faire un deux secondes deux
mois et aujourd'hui son seconde derrière
eh bien j'ai réussi à garder trois
secondes à reprendre trois secondes sur
vous alors c'était utile nécessaire que
vous avez c'est aujourd'hui je pense que
c'est très utile pour tout le monde
pour les fabricants français pour tout
le monde football bathenay s'est
malheureusement blessé à l'entraînement
ce matin il ne pourra reprendre sa place
dans l'équipe de france avant trois mois
et sera donc indisponible pour la
fameuse coupe du monde ce qui ouvre une
brèche sérieuse en attaque enfin en
natation l'américaine signa ou dead
vient à nouveau de battre la meilleure
performance mondiale du 400 m mais comme
elle a nagé dans un bassin de 25 mètres
il s'agit bien de la meilleure
performance mondiale et non pas du
record du monde ce dernier s'établissant
dans un bassin olympique de 50 mètres
vers 23h30
c'est jean-louis burgat qui vous
présentera le dernier journal bonsoir
merci et à demain